the other question is who who would
Trump or DeSantis or whoever it might be
run against and people seem to still
think that Joe Biden is going to run now
at this point the machine is so out of
control the the the Band-Aids on top of
Band-Aids of stupidity here are are so
layered that I think it's possible he's
going to run everyone knows there's
something wrong with him his wife Dr
Jill Biden refuses to have him examined
remember that clip we would never have
him take a cognitive test who do you
think we are
but they keep pretending he's either
running or in charge here's cringe
jean-pierre's comment on just that from
yesterday
the president has said many times that
he intends to run I'm not going to go
beyond that that is for the president to
decide clearly
all right so I guess he's gonna run as
opposed to falling down the stairs or
falling up the stairs he's better at
falling up the stairs than falling down
the stairs stairs which is a certain
skill uh in and of itself
[Music]
thank you